danke danke danke danke
schön dass sie gekommen sind hallo was
ich sagen wollte ich bin
wissenschaftlich habe folgendes
herausgefunden dass HI-Virus löst gar
nicht AIDS aus und Krebs können wir mit
Vitamin C heilen ja wirklich wirklich
meine Damen und Herren und das
allerwichtigste Tim Klimawandel Tim gibt
es gar nicht das sage ich als
Nobelpreisträger danke schön auf
Wiedersehen okay halt stopp Stopp das
ist natürlich alles totaler Quatsch und
wenn mir jemand so etwas erzählt ist
meine erste Frage eigentlich immer was
sind deine Quellen aber was ist wenn die
Quellen dieser drei Aussagen
Nobelpreisträger sind denn so ist es
immer mal wieder sagen Nobelpreisträger
nach ihrer Auszeichnung totalen Quatsch
das ganze wird im forschungskreisen
schon scherzhaft nur belkrankheit
genannt aber wieso sagen solche
anscheinend hoch intelligenten Menschen
so einen Unsinn lass uns den mal auf den
Grund gehen herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge dr Watson
[Musik]
das ein paar Nobelpreisträger nach ihrer
Auszeichnung mit fragwürdigen Statements
auffallen ist tatsächlich ein gängiger
Mythos aber ist da wirklich was dran da
ist zum Beispiel Luke montanier der
davon überzeugt ist dass Homöopathie
wirklich funktioniert oder charishee der
von der Existenz von Geistern überzeugt
war aber wie bei den meisten Mythen gilt
auch hier natürlich mehr als ein Running
Gag ist die nobelkrankheit nicht
wirklich im Grunde genommen handelt es
sich hier eher um weniger Ausnahmen als
die Norm aber eigentlich ist das ja
schon ziemlich paradox Menschen die
zumindest im öffentlichen Bild zu den
schlausten der schlauen gehören sagen
ziemlich unwissenschaftliche Dinge sind
das also ein paar dumme Ausreißer naja
so einfach ist das tatsächlich nicht
erstmal was ist denn überhaupt schlau
und was ist dumm wenn man an schlaue
Menschen denkt dann wahrscheinlich
zuerst an Intelligenz und was man auf
jeden Fall feststellen kann ist dass
Intelligenz eine Rolle dabei spielt in
welchem macht oder Prestige Position man
es in der Wirtschaft Politik oder auch
der Wissenschaft bringt Quellen zu allen
unseren Aussagen findet ihr natürlich
wie immer unten ganz transparent in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt aber der
Begriff Intelligenz an sich ist schon
etwas schwieriger zu fassen ein Versuch
ihn zu messen wären zum Beispiel
IQ-Tests aber wir sind ganz schön
umstritten da sie einfach nicht das
gesamte Spektrum an Intelligenz erfassen
können es ist einfach nicht vollends
definiert was Intelligenz überhaupt ist
nur weil jemand einen hohen IQ-Wert hat
ist diese Person noch lange nicht
allumfassend intelligent das führt zum
einen dazu dass Menschen die wir für
intelligent halten sich gar nicht
unbedingt herausragend intelligent
Verhalten zum anderen macht Intelligenz
einen auch nicht zum Übermenschen man
unterliegt weiterhin dem menschlichen
Verhalten und Menschen machen nun mal
Fehler auch sehr intelligente Menschen
ein Fehlschluss den viele ziehen ist
beispielsweise die appeal to apology
fellacy auf Deutsch das
autoritätsargument das bedeutet dass ich
den Titel einer Person wie Professor
Nobelpreisträger Ministerpräsident oder
Unternehmenschef als Argument nutze also
einfach gesagt es muss stimmen weil das
hat ja diese wichtige Person hier gesagt
für Menschen außerhalb der
wissenschaftsblase ist der Nobelpreis so
etwas wie ein Zertifikat für einen
universal Gelehrten Menschen die so klug
sind dass sie den Nobelpreis bekommen
können ja einfach nichts falsches sagen
oder und damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Punkt denn es wird oftmals gar nicht
nachgeschaut für welchen
Themenschwerpunkt diese Forscher ihre
Nobelpreis erhalten haben zum Beispiel
William shocklate er hat eine Nobelpreis
in Physik erhalten und sich in späteren
Jahren eher in die Bereiche der Genetik
und Biologie begeben wovon er aber keine
Ahnung hatte das Resultat waren
unwissenschaftliche rassistische
Äußerungen für die er zu recht scharf
platziert wurde daran sieht man ganz gut
ein Titel alleine macht eine Aussage
noch lange nicht richtig trotzdem
erfüllen Titel und Auszeichnungen
natürlich eine Funktion und
grundsätzlich ist es erstmal nicht
falsch bei einem Schnupfen dem Doktor
mehr zu vertrauen als dem Nachbarn falls
Sie also mal auf ein autoritätsargument
trefft ist es wichtig genauer
hinzuschauen ist die Autorität
vertrauenswürdig und wird sie korrekt
zitiert geht sie auf Gegenargumente ein
und kann sie diese schlüssig widerlegen
und liegt die Autorität überhaupt im
relevanten Sachgebiet es gibt nämlich
genug Menschen die sich gerne außerhalb
ihres Spezialgebietes äußern und so
agieren als wären sie dort Experten das
ganze nennt sich dann Achtung ultra
crappy darryannism einfach gesagt
Menschen die unter diese Kategorie
fallen denken sie wären allwissend und
überlegen nicht lange bevor sie ihre
Meinung äußern und diese als die
Wahrheit darstellen
mit dieser Allwissenheit identifizieren
sich insbesondere Menschen in
Machtpositionen sei es ein
Nobelpreisträger ein CEO oder ein
Politiker Menschen in Machtpositionen
entwickeln oft fünf Neigungen die sie
zur Unvernunft verleiten und das sind
unrealistische Optimismus Egozentrik
Allwissenheit
allmachtsgefühl und ein Gefühl der
Unverwundbarkeit doch wie man schon zu
Spiderman sagte aus großer Macht folgt
auch große Verantwortung insbesondere
wenn einem so viele Menschen ihr
Vertrauen schenken
diese vermeintliche Allwissenheit äußert
sich dann auch im dannen kruger-effekt
je weniger ich über ein Feld weiß desto
eher glaube ich es verstanden zu haben
und tatsächlich das ganz unabhängig
davon wie intelligent ein Mensch ist
fange ich zum Beispiel an mich in ein
Thema einzulesen dann denke ich relativ
schnell alles darüber zu wissen mit der
Zeit relativiert sich das dann aber bis
hin zu dem Punkt an dem ich denke dass
ich eigentlich überhaupt keine Ahnung
mehr habe weil ich dann erst merke wie
viele Unterthemen es gibt die ich noch
gar nicht angerührt habe dieser erste
Peak ist jedoch besonders kritisch und
die Ursache vieler Falschaussagen mixt
man das mit großen Erfolgen dann ist die
Überschätzung unter Umständen sogar noch
größer heutzutage ist die Wissenschaft
so sehr spezialisiert dass sich sogar
ein Nobelpreisträger der die PCR-Methode
entwickelt hat besser nicht über das
HI-Virus äußern sollte wenn ihr mehr
über diesen Effekt erfahren wollt dann
findet ihr hier noch mal ein ganzes
Video von mir dazu
[Musik]
die meisten von uns kommen aus einer
Vielzahl von Gründen zu ihren
überzeugenungen die oft wenig mit
empirischen beweisen und logischen
Überlegungen zu tun haben vielmehr
prägen Faktoren wie Gruppendruck
bildungserfahrungen und lebenseindrücke
die persönlichen Einstellungen die uns
in Verbindung mit zahlreichen sozialen
und kulturellen Einflüssen zu unseren
Überzeugungen führen denn diese
Überzeugungen bilden den Grundstein der
notwendig für den Zusammenhalt einer
jeden Gemeinschaft ist es ist quasi dass
wir Gefühl ohne sie würden wir nicht
dazu gehören deswegen sortieren wir als
Individuum Informationen und wählen
immer diejenigen aus die unsere
Überzeugungen am meisten bestätigen und
wir ignorieren auch oder rationalisieren
alle anderen zu merken ab welchem Punkt
man ohne es zu hinterfragen nach einer
Überzeugung handelt das ist die Kunst
und wirklich wichtig und weil das so
schwierig ist kennt man das in der
Psychologie als den bestätigungsfehler
oder auch confirmation byes wenn wir
erst einmal eine Theorie im Kopf
aufgestellt haben an die wir und die
unsere Werte bestätigt dann ist unser
Gehirn ganz schön gut darin nach
Beweisen für diese Theorie in unserer
Umwelt zu suchen alles was wiederum
gegen unsere neue These spricht wird
übergangen oder hat es zumindest nicht
so leicht in unserer Erinnerung zu
bleiben die Komfortzone zu verlassen und
umzudenken ist eben anstrengend und
andere mögliche Blickwinkel
durchzudenken genauso man muss dafür
seine Werte hinterfragen was mit großen
Unsicherheiten einhergeht aber es lohnt
sich die eigene Bubble zu verlassen um
Neues zu lernen und sich
weiterentwickeln zu können beruflich und
persönlich wer aber auf diese Chance
verzichtet lässt die Möglichkeit
ungenutzt außerordentliches zu erreichen
und zu erleben ganz drastisch
ausgedrückt in der Komfortzone zu
verbleiben bedeutet langfristig
Stillstand
okay lass uns das alles mal
zusammenfassen natürlich soll die
Lektion nicht sein dass man Menschen mit
akademischem Titel oder einer hohen
Position einfach nicht mehr vertrauen
darf sondern dass Ideen immer nur so gut
sind wie die Argumente die dafür
sprechen unabhängig von demjenigen der
sie ausspricht wir sollten Ideen und
Argumente immer unabhängig vom Absender
betrachten und sie für sich stehend
evaluieren wir alle glauben dumme Sachen
verbreiten und verteidigen sie sogar ich
glaube davon kann sich keiner frei
machen es sollte ein größerer Fokus
darauf gelegt werden wie man
Informationen auf Richtigkeit prüft wie
kam der Wissenschaftler zu seinen
Aussagen wie breit ist das
Beratergremium von der Politikerin
aufgestellt überzeugtens ihr das
Charisma des Firmenchefs oder wirklich
der Inhalt seiner Aussagen gute
Anzeichen sind in meinen Augen wenn
jemand Unsicherheiten klar kommuniziert
sich also auch mal nicht sicher ist und
wenn jemand seine oder ihre Quellen
offen legt
es bleibt aber ein komplexes Thema woran
erkennt man Fakten woran erkennt man
gute Quellen und was ist die Wahrheit
genau darüber hat Jakob von Breaking Lab
ein tolles Video gemacht dass ich euch
hier mal verlinkt habe wenn ihr nach all
dem trotzdem noch Ambitionen auf den
Nobelpreis vor allem in Medizin habt
dann solltet ihr jetzt aufpassen denn am
18 Oktober organisiert proendes dobio
initial eine Veranstaltung für junge
nachwuchswissenschaftler:innen aus dem
Hochschulen in NRW hier könnt ihr euch
über Fördermöglichkeiten im Life
science-bereich informieren also zum
Beispiel in den Bereichen Gesundheit
Medizintechnik oder der Wirkstoffsuche
ihr könnt bei der Veranstaltung neue
Projektideen entwickeln oder bereits
vorhandene schärfen und ihr könnt auch
einen Vortrag von mir hören denn ich
werde dort über spannende
Zukunftstechnologien berichten die ich
mir bei verschiedenen Drehs in
Deutschland schon ansehen durfte mit
go-bio initial will das
Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung hochriskante Entwicklungen mit
erkennbaren Innovationspotenzial fördern
und sie auch schon früh auf spätere
Kommerzialisierung ausrichten bis zum 4
oktober könnt ihr euch noch anmelden und
dann sehen wir uns in Essen oder online
denn es ist eine Hybride Veranstaltung
die auch online gestreamt wird ein Link
mit weiteren Infos findet Ihr wie immer
unten in der Videobeschreibung und da
könnt ihr euch dann auch anmelden okay
was mir noch wichtig ist zu betonen es
ist völlig in Ordnung Fehler zu machen
leider habe ich das Gefühl dass das in
unserer Gesellschaft noch nicht ganz
angekommen ist es sollte kein Thema sein
sich offen eingestehen zu dürfen wenn
etwas mal nicht so toll gelaufen ist
oder man etwas schlichtweg nicht weiß
ohne schwach zu wirken oder seine
Kompetenz zu verlieren also habt den Mut
eure denkbarbe zu verlassen und über den
Tellerrand hinauszuschauen auch wenn es
manchmal ein bisschen ungemütlich werden
könnte und das wichtigste wie immer
bleibt neugierig euer Cedric meine Damen
und Herren was ich sagen wollte
das HI-Virus das löst gar keinen Krebs
aus
das stimmt sogar tatsächlich das stimmt
[Applaus]